we've all heard that old saying a way to
a person's heart is through their
stomach well a new poll says that's true
the good news network reports a one poll
survey of over 2 000 adults said over
half of them said that was true for them
the poll also found 75 of people said
good food can actually change their mood
uh yes
and 62 said yes that it was very
important for potential romantic
partners to be just as excited about
food as they are drew yeah and i don't
know about you but at breakfast i'm
thinking about lunch at lunch and
thinking about dinner and at dinner i'm
thinking about breakfast tomorrow yeah
so could you ever date a person who was
like um not a foodie
um not even a little
but i do have a cute story actually um
so i it sucks that my best friend is
cameron diaz because it sounds like i'm
name dropping we met when i was 14 and
she was 16. junior model worked at a
coffee house
so we've been you know sisters ever
since anyway okay so i drove her one
night she had a date
with this guy benji
and she was like i really really like
him and um
i really want to make a special meal for
him cute um and um hashtag hookum
and um so i drove her to the grocery
store and she picked out this like
perfectly you know set meal that she
wanted
made it for him and of course i asked
her the next day i'm like how did it go
and she was like it worked
the meal worked they are married and
they have a daughter and it ended
happily ever after so what food can do i
a testament yeah like i remember driving
my girlfriend so that she could plan a
meal
to make her way through a man's stomach
into his heart and it worked they're
married with kids and it's just like so
i see the proof totally last night i
made a white bean chicken chili for
wellington and when he tasted that he
looked at me and i knew he loved me
oh that's so exciting
well speaking of culinary wonders we
have got a new spin on one of the
coziest snacks of all time and today's
food
all right
so mega talent scarlett johansson she's
got a tony a bafta countless golden
globes but there's a new achievement to
add to that list of things and it's the
reinvented pizza bite that's right check
out snow days pizza bite they are
organic grain free and cook up in
minutes in the oven it's the same cozy
classic that we all love but this time
it's made with top of the line
ingredients and you know pizza is a
gateway food for me so i'm really taking
one for scarjo here okay but these are
grain free
and oh my god oh
my i just took one bite i couldn't even
finish my sentence rossi
i'm not even listening to you these are
not only grain free they're guilt-free
these are incredible i also tastes very
very delicious um lots of flavor
incredible umami mm-hmm
i'm getting like imagine if you had a
pizza
with like with like a spinach oh there's
different colors
there's different flavors what she has
some with meat than squash vegetables
and
like i said look at this one look inside
look look look
i know scarlett she really doesn't mess
around she knows what's amazing out
there and she's never going to
compromise
that one's even better oh my god this is
incredible get out get out of here
i mean
we'll be right back
[Music]